[Music]
the hands of a woman and playing cards
frame the stage as Carmen fights for her
freedom we are in 19th century Seville
and at the Bregenz Festival on the
shores of Lake Constance
British stage designer s Devlin created
the huge and extravagant sculpture after
a great deal of thought
I mean it's a massive responsibility
when you've been looking forward to
working here on this lake for twenty
years and then when you decide to commit
to one idea it's not like you can do
four different scenes it has to be one
so we did audition at least four
different ideas before we head on this
one and it was a great source of anxiety
and sleepless nights Carmen drives men
crazy but in the end she would rather be
alone than lose her freedom the 59 cards
represent the fateful moment in the
third act when Carmen reads them to find
out what the future holds in store
Carmen was the right piece to do here
because of the pool between freedom air
and fate the water so we felt that the
card could be an object that could
mediate between the forces of uplift and
undertow the lake setting is a challenge
for any production and designer the
cosmos itself asserts its presence its
act one really belongs to nature it
belongs to the sunset it belongs to
whatever the waters doing it belongs to
the birds and the ducks really and
whatever we're doing is us trying to get
the audience's attention away from the
bigger thing and then quietly as you
enter into the sort of twenty fifth
sixth seventh minute of the performance
the sky starts to close down and the
focus starts to become very intense on
the stage and then it's dark so it's a
real handover from nature to art
actually the set will remain in place
for two years anew if temporary landmark
in Bregenz
[Music]
as vicious it's impressive
you can see it from a long way away and
on its webcam it looks so real the
fingers and the flaking nail varnish
it's beautiful it's incredible the the
way everything is it seems to be
floating it took a crew of 74 years to
put the amazing set together there are
people here who know exactly what's
gonna work they know all about the
variation of a metre and a half in type
so our stage level changes by one metre
and a half during the course of the run
we work closely with the team here and
we had a shared model I've been
travelling during the four years and
there's still this model that's being
communicated back and forth from Bregenz
to Los Angeles from Bregenz to Tokyo's
Farnborough Ken's to London always do we
move the card a bit this way do we move
the card a bit that way should the hands
be a bit this a bit that I mean endless
iterations video productions and
computer animations keep everything in
motion as Dublin has been designing
stages for two decades she creates
kinetic sculptures meshed with light and
film for opera dance film theater runway
shows and concerts for pop stars like
Beyonce
Bono u2 and Kanye West the process
whether one is interpreting lyrics by a
contemporary pop singer or lyrics by a
19th century opera librettist the
process is the same you study the lyrics
you have an instinct towards what is
needed as an environment to present
those lyrics and that story
but this commission it turns out has
been different I've got to come back a
residents permanent residency that's
what I'm after
yeah I'll build my house up the hill get
my team located yeah just keep me here
that would definitely be a win-win
situation a happy designer and more
delighted audiences Carmen runs until
the season ends on August the 20th and
will return next summer
[Music]